cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com bill malugan says breaking
one of the largest mass illegal
Crossings we have ever seen took place
in Eagle Pass Texas this morning border
patrol Source has done this over 2 200
people crossed since midnight it
happened right next to the Port of Entry
as illegal immigrants continue to ignore
the Biden admin messaging of do not come
and do not fear the promised
consequences of Crossing illegally
videos from Source in Mexico and our Fox
drone team I mean look at these videos
this is Bonkers you've got people in New
York screaming at the politicians saying
stop this and it's only getting worse
what's the solution do we do we have to
set up we got to build a wall gotta
build a big beautiful wall from Cedar or
expand you know you the the US is
beautiful there's a lot of open land in
the U.S if the government wants to be so
a part of this they should take some of
the funding we're given billions of
dollars to to Ukraine no one knows where
the money's going take take two billion
dollars and go in that area in New York
where there was nothing and build them a
city or something I don't know
I'm sorry I'm sorry take the two billion
dollars get a bunch of buses that are
very nice and very comfortable and bring
them back on it and we send them back
home you send them back yeah the
challenge with deportation is that if
they're not Mexican citizens we can't go
to Mexico and be like we're sending
these people to your country within
reason so they end up getting flown back
to Guatemala or Honduras or wherever
they may be from many of these people
not a lot I'm saying uh I'm not saying
majority but a lot of them are coming
from South America and even Africa
they'll fly from Africa to Brazil and
then Trek all the way up to Southern
border where they know they can just
walk in here but them but Venezuelans
coming illegally through Mexico into the
U.S and is kind of like if Chris gave
you a Dr Pepper and you spilled it on me
I can't blame Chris because you're the
one that feels like Mexico is the one
that's letting them across the border
yeah so of course yeah hell yeah we can
send them back to Mexico I'm just saying
like
there are certain circumstances where we
go to Mexico and it's like hey we have a
bunch of these citizens that are not our
citizens you can't send them here it's
like it's of course like a finger trap
they want it it's like if it was easy it
would have been solved already we got it
we gotta how about this I think it's a
good point take all that money that went
to Ukraine and just spend it on
transportation for these people back to
their homes and securing the border and
stopping this because we can't sustain
this economically when when these people
are screaming at AOC like get these
people out it's because they're saying
we're cutting services we're cutting
police we're cutting you know your tax
benefits to fund these other people who
had just arrived people are like this is
insane I've been paying into the system
and now it's being taken from me by
these strangers who are coming in and
effectively stealing from us they should
just say you are not welcome to just
illegally enter all immigrants are
welcome in the United States but you got
to do it legally we could also maybe
instead of investing in slave labor in
China maybe start building factories in
these Central American South American
countries that are more the more that
our neighbors are also disagree we
should build factors in the United
States for Americans yeah I mean that's
that's definitely yeah the first thing
to do but maybe help these other
countries that are to the south of us
maybe have a better economy so they
don't want to come here we we already
spend the money in China might as well
get closer to our home it's kind of an
interesting argument like would it be
better to make it in at least in North
America or at least in this in South
America than in China and potentially
alleviate our immigration be good for
the climate too you know not as long as
ship rides right for the cargo I mean I
ultimately yeah manufacturing jobs
should come back here so yeah it's not a
bad point like it is
n't we're willing to ship manufacturing
somewhere else but we're saying oh these
people are fleeing economic and
political turmoil yet we are not
adjusting anything we're doing yeah my
number one option is Bring Back
manufacturing back to the United States
but I mean that's not happening either
so why is AOC so confident in just
telling New Yorkers how it is like this
why is she just out there like they're
all yelling at her and she sat there
like she's not listening we don't care
anybody she's just she's just not listen
with none of the people of the commuter
saying and she's why does she feel that
comfortable she could just go in there
and no one's gonna do nothing
because nobody can vote her out so she
doesn't so she's gonna win her primary
because she she got like 14 000 votes
she gets a primary so she doesn't care
what one protest thinks because the
average person is not voting and that's
why people need to go out man I'm
telling you I think AOC could easily
lose her District especially over this
but people have to go there and just
start spreading the word informing
people because what happens is the
average person who votes in the primary
which effectively gets her elected the
average person who votes in the in the
Congressional elections they just vote
for Democrats they don't care who it is
AOC knows that's got to stop the only
people screaming and people pay
attention guess what you're few and far
between so she's thinking to herself I
can say whatever I want no it doesn't
matter Nancy Pelosi said she held up a
glass of water and said
people will vote for a glass of water if
you put a d on it in Meyer aoc's
District they know it they know that
this note this is what Republicans need
to do Republicans need to invest a
stupid amount of money in in her
District
that's it like they're doing in Texas
the the Democrats are doing that in
Texas to try to really get as much
influence they can there but it's just I
don't know looking at the parties it
just gets confusing because it's half a
unit party the Republican party is
pretty weak right it's it's the the the
the the Democrats come off very evil to
me right now there's a lot of things
that I'm seeing that I'm like they're
evil man I got a Super Chat like I was
like I also want to join the military
but I can't with Joe I can't I won't
join Joe Biden's military that's like
that's the evil yeah yeah but it's not
even that I mean it was Millie you know
I mean like even even if uh uh Trump
gets reelected is he going to clean
house and bring in better leaders he has
to if he doesn't I'm going to be
suspicious to him I mean we're hoping he
does but he did it the first time and
that's why I am suspicious of him
because he didn't do it before so so the
general idea right now is Trump is your
best bet it doesn't mean it's a good bet
I should say it's it's your best bet
it's a good bet in that sense it doesn't
mean you're going to get what you want
he's a people pleaser he's like do you
see him talking about abortion and how
he's going to make a deal with the
Democrats and he's like I'm Gonna Make a
Deal that Everyone likes about abortion
15 weeks nah it's like dude stop trying
to make everybody happy man that's not
it didn't work the first time you can't
just you can't just be an Entertainer if
you want to be in politics he got
clowned pretty hard by the covid team
too the fauci and the Burks they they
just ran him you know that was tough for
me I just want anybody to come in at
that that stops the unjust that we're
seeing in the direction of culture and
society that we're seeing I think it's
it's getting pretty ugly and it needs to
be nipped in the butt and that's why I
just I just keep on putting my faith in
God and trying to be closer in my
community because I know that's what I
can do as my part this this is the most
important thing that people can do right
now because a lot of these problems that
we Face are daunting and a lot of people
want Simple Solutions like if I vote for
Trump trump does the job you know
whatever Trump is a good thing to do
spreading the word first and foremost is
more important because for every person
you convince to vote for and it's not
necessarily Trump it's for somebody
who's actually going to uphold our
values and trying keep Americans safe
and and better our economy and better
the world convincing people to vote
better multiplies your vote for everyone
you convince but the most important
thing is always going to be I mean first
let's go in the hierarchy the least one
of the least important things in terms
of fixing all the problems is going to
be just voting for the President right
because you gotta more important than
that convince other people to vote for a
good president more important than that
convince people to vote for good members
of Congress more important than that
convince people to vote locally for your
State Rep state senator city council you
name it that's the stuff that is impact
on your city if everybody got everyone
to vote for good candidates at the local
level it starts to fix things from the
ground up then the next important thing
after all the Voting is said and done is
you got to succeed take care of your
family find a good job be physically
physically well stop eating the garbage
start exercising you know what I was
thinking as I was playing I'm playing
Baldur's Gate three I love this game and
it's such a popular game it's so big and
I'm thinking to myself how many people
are playing this game right now and
they're not upping their own stats when
you play games like this you level up
you get XP appearance points you level
up now your character is stronger
unlocking new abilities and I'm like how
many people play this game and love that
idea but don't do it for themselves that
that I'm like that's to be the training
program right that's the solutions man
you're offering Solutions this is what
you do you want a training program
someone and I'm sure this exists already
a personal trainer should create the RPG
training program where you get you you
level up and then they track your stats
and then they show you your your your
your your avatar or whatever it's
addicting treat it like a video game
where you're actually breaking barriers
and then it can be like in order to get
like I mean like uh uh martial arts
belts is kind of like this yep you level
up you get the next level you want to
attain that you want to get I think
that's how you gotta approach it dude if
you could get crypto for that and it
measures your Biometrics you like held
the handles and it's like you've gained
two percent body fat and they put like a
dollar ninety in your bank account
whenever you're horny your wife gets a
little heart singing wait wait wait wait
hey this is an idea hey this is an idea
that might get you in trouble Ian it's
probably already in development right
now
that generates cryptocurrency when
you're when you're it's gonna like so
you got these apps like I'm wearing this
watch and it tracks vitals and stats and
stuff like that so once you reach a
certain degree of like health and stress
and it goes down you're earning more
crypto per day the more healthy you are
like lower resting heart rate less
stress the more crypto it generates
yeah you just gotta make sure the code
is free and that you're controlling
because they're going to be sending all
that data to some centralized debt
ideally they won't be but it's likely
that if you just grab some random app
it's gonna be sending marriages right
you could be like look babe my vitals
are saying that we haven't made love in
four days
have proven that I need some imagine if
you made a video game that like earned
me some money when you when you defeat a
bad guy and it drops a few gold pieces
you get bonus multipliers based on your
personal physical health and like things
if you could sum out
um figure out like learning if you get
paid to learn like you go down and you
you're looking at the grass and you can
somehow discern like what kind of plant
that is uh I don't know that's complex
but we can we can actually like if
you're playing a game like Starfield or
Baldur's Gate or whatever No One's Gonna
do this because there's no money in
investing in it it's just a social good
that No One's Gonna want to do but
imagine it's like oh you get 1.1 times
your experience points if you're if
you're at average Health Fitness if
you're above average you get 1.2 times
and if you're unhealthy you get minus
one yeah rested XP again so it's like a
way to encourage people this is this
this is the problem right now is the
United States is basically just this
gluttonous state of the seven I
shouldn't even say gluttonous it's all
the seven deadly sins people are not
taking care of themselves they're not
planning for for uh long term they're
not planning their families they're not
bettering their their bodies they're
just chasing after those dopamine hits
and it's resulting in decay
this would be a perfect opportunity for
like a really good health insurance
company
but they're all in bed with big Pharma
so they'd actually want to do that but
they do this stuff like insurance
companies already do this where it's
like if you submit your health data the
lower your rates and things like that
sounds like a like well
it's kind of scary if you think about it
but I don't know man is it is it is it
is it that bad the challenge is what are
they doing with your data that may be
nefarious because there's going to be
corrupt people there but the idea that
you get to pay less because you take
care of yourself I think is a good thing
yeah they pay you in crypto because you
save them money
I like the insurance and civilization
except that if they are like did you not
get vaccinated for some random thing we
think you should be then maybe it will
make you pay more for your insurance
this year yeah there's ambiguity and
what they Define as being healthy or
making good choices they could stop
making prices up at the hospital take
your kid in for a fever yeah Motrin will
do it two thousand four hundred and
twenty two dollars you're like that's a
made-up number thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time